Speaker 1: Let's talk about deceptive headlines
that can be written to achieve political goals.
I hope that this segment is a good snapshot
of how headlines can be used to distort and
to influence and to push a particular narrative
that may be interesting to one media outlet versus
another. So what happened? While Joe Biden was
recently asked during his current trip to Asia
about Chinese aggression towards Taiwan, now
that's a legitimate issue. We've talked about
it on this program. Will China see the chaos of
what's happening in Ukraine thanks to the Russian
invasion, as maybe an opening in which they could
make a military move against Taiwan? So China,
Taiwan, that's the issue. It's a real issue.
It's a legitimate issue. President Joe Biden
was asked about it and Joe Biden confirmed if
China invaded Taiwan, the U.S. would intervene.
And that's been American policy for a long time.
So let's look at the actual question and answer.
This is the source material for the topic and
the subsequent headlines we're going to look at.
Speaker 2: It didn't want to get involved in the
Ukraine conflict militarily for obvious reasons.
Are you willing to get involved militarily
to defend Taiwan if it comes to that?
Speaker 3: Yes.
Speaker 2: You are.
Speaker 3: That's a commitment we made.
Speaker 1: Okay. So that's not news. It's
there's nothing there that's actually newsworthy.
There's something called the one-China policy.
You can agree with the one-China policy or you
can disagree with it. But the policy has been
dating all the way back to 1979. It was first
started stated in 1972. The U.S. acknowledges
that China on either side of the Taiwan Strait,
maintain there is but one China and that Taiwan
is a part of China. That's the United States
position. Now, in 2016, Donald Trump said the U.S.
isn't necessarily bound by the one-China policy.
And lots of people said, oh my goodness, Trump
is trying to change the one-China policy.
But then in a phone call in 2017 that Trump had
with Xi Jinping, they talked about a number of
different things. And Trump agreed at the request
of President Xi to honor the one-China policy.
Okay, so we have that. We also have
the Taiwan Relations Act from 1979,
and we have the six assurances, as they're
called, that Reagan gave to Taiwan in 1982,
which say that if Taiwan violates the principles
the U.S. believes in, or if a rather if China
violates the principles that the U.S. believes
in, the U.S. would help Taiwan to defend itself
if if China were to invade, the United States
would help Taiwan in that situation. So this
has been policy for a really long time. So Biden
is asked during the press conference, well, if
China attacks, would the U.S. help defend Taiwan
in the United States? President says, yes, that's
the commitment we made. It's not news. Biden
is essentially saying the stuff we've agreed to
for the last 40 years, we're going to abide by it.
That's it. That's the story. Check out how every
News Corp media outlet covered it. And by
meet by News Corp, we mean Fox, Fox Business,
Wall Street Journal. The Wall Street Journal
titled their article Bill Biden Says U.S. Would
Intervene Militarily If China Invaded Taiwan. Fox
News says U.S. military will defend Taiwan if it
comes to that, Biden says. Fox Business Segment
Says Biden Says U.S. will intervene if China
invades Taiwan. Now, again, it's not about these
headlines being literally false. It's the fact
that they're being written specifically to further
the idea of Biden's out there looking for wars,
Biden's out there looking for military conflict,
and it was Trump who was keeping us out of wars.
This has been the narrative in the George W Bush
era, the right loved war. They loved spreading
democracy and all of this different stuff. And
then Trump came in and Trump said the Iraq war was
a bad idea, even though previously Trump had said,
I would have gone into Iraq. Doesn't matter. Trump
came in and said Iraq was bad, which is true. Just
he's a hypocrite on it. And he said, Hillary will
get us into wars, but I won't. I'm going to keep
us out of wars and get us out of more places.
And then the claim made about Joe Biden was
Biden's going to get us into wars, Biden's blood
thirsty, Biden's war hungry, even though there
was no such evidence of that. And so they want
to write headlines that will further that. And
most of the Fox audience probably doesn't realize
most of the Wall Street Journal audience doesn't
realize the U.S. has previously said we would help
to defend Taiwan in such a case. Biden's not
treading new ground here. Biden's not changing
policy. He's not an. Announcing new policy.
But the story that Fox wants to tell is here's
Biden once again looking for military problem. So
they'll say, look at Biden wanting to intervene.
Look at Biden wanting to interject and inject
the military. The truth is, Biden saying,
I'm not changing the 40 year policy that we've
had now comparatively. Reuters had a more
straightforward headline for this story. Reuters
called it No Change in U.S. Policy towards Taiwan,
says White House Official. Now, it's not only Fox
opting for the more salacious headlines, most of
them do it. CNN had a similar one, but it's at
least more fair. CNN's headline was Biden says
U.S. Would Respond Militarily If China Attacked
Taiwan, but White House insists there is no policy
change and indeed there isn't. So it's really
important to understand how to research these
things directly. If you were to Google one China
policy six assurances to Taiwan, U.S. relationship
to China and Taiwan, you would realize there's
not a newsworthy element here. Joe Biden is just
saying like, yeah, this is the policy and we're
going to stick to the policy. The story is Biden
doesn't unilaterally change anything when it comes
to China and Taiwan. That doesn't really make for
a very exciting headline. So that's the genesis,
the oranges, for lack of a better term, of a bunch
of these headlines and hopefully instructive in
understanding how these narratives can be woven.